family is calling on the community to
help locate their missing food truck the
amigo taco truck was stolen around 3 30
a.m on friday at flamingo and decatur
kate houston joins us live in the studio
tonight after speaking with the family
this afternoon kate yes amigo taco is
run by sisters carla and eileen enriquez
they're currently working towards their
business degree at unlv and although
they are very frustrated this happened
they're hopeful that their food truck
will be found me and my sister manage
the food truck and it's also an
opportunity since we're business majors
it's an opportunity for us to get
practice besides internships carla and
eileen enriquez opened amigo taco only
two months ago and just want to get back
to work it's a really great opportunity
for us and again we manage each other
while managing the food truck
surveillance video shows a 1996 to 1999
silver dodge ram towing the amigo taco
food truck out of the amigo tire lot on
decatur and flamingo enriquez believes
this was planned noting the people
responsible broke the lock to their back
gate and knew to hook the food truck
onto their car we imagine that they have
been watching our kicks pick up and drop
off the truck here because they knew
their schedule and they knew when we
wouldn't be here enriquez says they've
posted to various social media pages
locally as well as in california and
arizona hoping to get the word out just
a little
step like we have to to pass
fortunately we have the insurance cover
and well we're going to start over
enriquez says they wanted amigo taco to
be a place family and friends could
gather while they're upset this has
happened they're hopeful the food truck
will be found while this is a step back
in our project and now we're growing
into the going into the business
community we take this as an opportunity
to grow
the enriquez family has filed a report
with metro police right now they're
waiting for a detective to be assigned
to their case they're asking anyone with
information on their food truck or those
who have seen it to contact police